certain type of [ __ ] legitimacy I'm
saying greetings from podcast Ville the
Church of what's happened now is brought
to you by hymns for hymns calm again the
church is brought to you by for hymns
calm a one-stop shop for hair loss skin
care and sexual wellness for men let me
tell you something at least 70% of men
lose their hair by the age of 35 the
thing is when you start to notice hair
loss it's too late it's easy to keep the
hair you got then to replace their you
lost all right let me do it let's do
this what I'm going to do for you is
tremendous alright because for him is
not common like I said there's a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
and sexual wellness we connect you with
real doctors and medical grade solutions
to treat hair loss without having to
break the bank the understand I'm trying
to say to you
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair fda-approved prescription
solutions backed by science I'm gonna
tell you something my listeners the
family the church family I'm gonna give
you a trauma month you start to lose
your head listen [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
start to lose their hair forget about
that I'm gonna give you a trial month of
hymns for 5 hours today right now while
supplies last see the website for full
details this will cost you hundreds of
dollars if you want to adopt it but none
under the whole pharmacy what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna give my family the
church right now a trial month of hymns
for just $5 today gold for hymns calm /
Joey go-to for hymns calms last Joey
that's for hymns dot-com / Joey this is
the way to go number two you've heard me
talk about me on these for 760 is now
the fun they're comfy on these that feel
as good as they look they're comfortable
they grab your little nutsack everything
is nice and dry tremendous you
understand me you know I wear me on
these little jujitsu whether I go to
ballet whether I go to the track in the
summer heat I got the me on these you
know why because it keeps the moisture
they keeps the nutsack nice and dry
sometimes you take a pee you tap the
helmet
a little piece stays on your helmet it
causes a thousand things not with me
undies why because of their soft cotton
fabric that you
nobody else got you understand me so go
to me on these calm right now I'm gonna
get your 15 percent off your first pair
with Free Shipping and 100% money-back
guarantee guarantee go to me undies calm
right now / yo you again that's me on
these dot-com / join for the best man on
the way yeah we're gonna have kick this
[ __ ] mule Lee that means I want
you to call me papi that's like telling
you I love when you call me big papa
lonely and Puerto Rican you know saying
oh we got every throat in the house you
got my main man Lee sorry yeah you're
asking me Joey what the [ __ ] is Eric
wrote so we're gonna find that right now
I'm gonna tell you every reason who I
have them on the podcast what's
happening you're good your songs right
yeah beautiful it's been a great week so
far
Eric what's happening brother not much
man I'm happy to be here thank you so
much it's [ __ ] awesome you were gonna
tell the story slowly we're gonna get in
for this I want to introduce you to the
world I saw you singing for the choir
and [ __ ] Savage I'm like this kids a
[ __ ] Savage nobody's seen this
[ __ ] kid and when I did my Netflix
thing up at the store I had you come up
that Sunday night and you leveled them
with Lee and there's a lot of topics you
know I [ __ ] I'm old Eric I'm getting
old and I have a lot of my mind I forget
things and I digest things a lot
differently than most people when Lee
says something to me I'll come back with
a rebuttal to him to explain it and
he'll though like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about that thing you said that
night I totally agree with you I'm the
one that [ __ ] up I'm one of those
people and always don't come to you and
you'll go what the [ __ ] that was two
weeks ago why'd you ask me about that
now because I processed and at four in
the morning one night a dream why would
[ __ ] Eric say something like this
fella how long you been doing comedy for
five years five yeah in April was why'd
you start I did you see in New York I
worked for Caroline's literally like two
days
and then I couldn't [ __ ] do it it was
I still have a check for 60 bucks that I
never [ __ ] picked up never were you a
doorman I was answering the phones yeah
that was how I got to meet Mooney that
was how I was answering phones and that
guy's his ticket sales would [ __ ] it
was impossible to keep up with so you
would just answer the phone and be like
thank you for calling caroline's and
then be told and what what happened was
if he you had to screen the calls so you
would get a [ __ ] ton of people calling
for Paul Mooney but then every once in
one of that guy's wife would [ __ ]
sneak through and you had to catch your
L so you put it through and you were
[ __ ] whoa
that's cats practice no were you
originally from where'd you grow up
Colorado what part of Colorado its
northeast the plains area like [ __ ]
farm town remember Greeley Greeley it's
like an hour from that so Howard North
agreeing yep that's [ __ ] crazy
Greeley smells so bad get closer to the
mic get closer to the mic like it's
Tuesday like in Isaiah the agree leave
really was my second comedy gig really
second comedy gig at the longest-running
one-nighter in history one of the top
five went longest lasting one night is
in history luck because I heard it was
still running up to a couple years ago
and it was there ten years before I
started
Jesus that's 30-some years it was a one
night of book by a guy named Bill Bauer
on Thursday nights who ran a motorcycle
shop every Thursday every Thursday Wow
and the ceiling was real low so if you
jump you bang your head on the ceiling
the place is great it was like they have
my pictures of like singers behind you
the ugliest artists like the worst
artists in the world was a picture of
Jimi Hendrix there was a picture of
Janis Joplin and there was a picture of
Bob Marley behind you committed calmly
however the audience is they're [ __ ]
great it's a college town number that
it's where the Broncos yeah I just I do
spring training
oh whatever the [ __ ] flow yeah we used
to go every year my mom was a huge
[ __ ] Broncos fat my uncle's hated him
but mom wasn't we'd go every summer so
now you're in Greeley Colorado let's
assume how old were you till you stayed
in Colorado I moved to New York when I
was 18 what made you want to go to the
earth without a thought you graduated in
high school so probably on the radar at
18 no to be honest I got into a
conservatory in New York because I
wanted to do theater okay I was a
theater nerd so I went there and I loved
it I loved the theater and just living
in New York for I lived there for like
four years and just pounding the
pavement auditions and [ __ ] like that
but then comedy was always something in
my life like I was raised by my grandpa
and I found his Richard Pryor tapes and
when I found those it was it was like
something forbidden and I [ __ ] loved
it that was that was the introduction in
boys on tapes albums CDs it was here and
now I remember that one it was here now
and it was a greatest hits like a lay
track yeah yeah
it was [ __ ] I remember like you'd
have to sneak to listen to others yeah I
that and like Eddie Murphy's delirious
you remember the language the first time
you heard that language how your head
felt the first time you heard not from
your parents because you heard it from
your parents but not used the way a
stand-up especially Richard Pryor
twisted around have you watched that
comedy on seeing them that series no I
started buying it finished other night
they had just a bunch of dirty comedy as
I was walking in the door and it was
brilliant
it was Redd Foxx doing all his arms
that's why I want to go back to the
house because that's my I grew up on
Almaty I'm saying yeah
look at this and the hand comes out over
here it's like cousin it gonna take the
Lysol and glass it this way just a
little side angle to make it go up hold
it for an hour what happened hold it I
was thinking about it but what the
[ __ ] were all here a week : now
alright so you listen who else did you
listen to as a young I listen I listen
to Redd Foxx everybody he had I would
listen to so yeah you got to wash your
ass that one [ __ ] Oh God I Eddie
Murphy delirious was another one because
I even listen much James Brown but when
I heard him do James Brown it it was the
fact that a grown man could do that with
his voice and I was like how the [ __ ] is
he making that sound that hey know that
that's a lyric that's James Brown need a
lyric I said well that's good that end
like the barbeque like just the pictures
that that guy could [ __ ] paint and so
it worked backwards though cuz clay said
my dad was a piece of [ __ ] so it was my
grandpa that raised me and he let me
just listen to whatever the [ __ ] I
wanted and I was like I want to listen
to that and it was Richard Pryor so I
put it it was actually a cassette tape
that's what I remember one of them was
Greatest Hits cuz it was an 8-track the
other one was here now I think that was
the cassette tape and he'd do mudbone
web ball and that that was when like we
were talking about one time outside
outside fourth-wall cuz you were talking
to Lee about don't go don't you go down
there [ __ ] with him Jews I don't know
money oh my god that's the funniest
that's and I remember that cuz in a
weird way that that brought me back to
when I was a kid and I was like there
was only one person who was like in
their 30s when I was a kid and I heard
them say that don't you go down there
part one of Jews without no money and I
knew right then I was like oh [ __ ] like
to me that that was just how you judge
people that you liked on what they knew
what how much
prior [ __ ] do they know do they know
like the you know everybody knows one
maybe the drinks always gets [ __ ] up
he always wants to fight you remember
that one right the oh he never wanted to
fight but he always wants to fight and
just the way that he would do that was
just the picture was [ __ ] there and I
was just this little kid and that was
that alone was hilarious dude now you
listening to all this how did you end up
a theater geek um honestly I don't I
don't know I that you could what the
[ __ ] was this movie I saw like American
Beauty I think it was and I remember cuz
it was a pretty conservative town and
the way that he looked at that
cheerleader cuz he wanted to [ __ ] her
really bad
I remember thinking like that shit's
true like I see my friends their parents
doing that [ __ ] and so when I saw that
on a movie everybody in our town hated
that [ __ ] movie and I was like oh
it's so true though so for some reason I
was like okay I like what what good
movies can do good movies can kind of
bring to light a truth just like when I
saw Goodfellas and like you know the
[ __ ] he starts laughing and then he
just stops laughing and everybody just
kind of cowards I was like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] actually happens in in scary rooms
like that so I don't know it was it was
something like that that I loved was
just the ability to to ask questions
like that and to just kind of poke truth
so I guess that's why I like comedy too
was you know when I was probably middle
school I found out about George Carlin
and it was specifically the you were all
diseased and it was that night when he I
remember seeing the HBO thing and he
said if there is a god if there is may
he strike this audience dead and I
remember my grandma was like [ __ ]
livid and I couldn't believe he'd
[ __ ] said that and that was when I
learned that stand-up could be
[ __ ] dangerous like that cuz it was
like this guy is talking about [ __ ] that
he should not be talking about so I I
grew up Catholic so I went to church
that that next day we were in catechism
and I started asking question like how
do we know there's a God God in the
world and people were like what what the
[ __ ] what's up I was like well I mean
think about they they've got us
believing this and we don't know we
really don't and you meet like and I was
a [ __ ] kid I didn't know what the
[ __ ] I was taught all I knew was hearing
him and all of the points that he was
making and I think it's been that way
ever since like just comics that that
can be funny and that talk about [ __ ]
that makes you think a little bit
differently and I mean we we talk about
that like that's the goal but to
actually do it and be in the room with
somebody when they're doing that [ __ ]
was it was just amazing it was like wow
I want to do this where does the closest
comedy club do because I went early I
went in like high school I think to a
comedy club really see I didn't go till
college um where'd you go to college it
was the American Musical and Dramatic
Academy and that was New York what was
the first comedy club you what time it
was Caroline's on Broadway okay who was
onstage it was Paul Mooney it was it was
to go watching or for you you know how
did you discover Paul Moy Chappell
Chappell show when he did the Mooney on
movies and they would do the synapses
about what the movie was about
and then the camera would just pan on
him and he'd he just shaped like that's
that [ __ ] grin Lemmy hadn't nope that
was a movie that offended me and then he
would talk about you know what was a
Brad Pitt
he's the last or know Tom Cruise he's
less MRI and then he did last summer
okay the Mexican with Brad Pitt and then
he goes I've got one how about the last
[ __ ] on earth starring Tom Hanks how
about that yeah it was just the the
cockiness and you felt like you were in
the room with that guy and negrodamus
and and all of that [ __ ] and so I was
like I my mom went out to visit me I was
like we should see this guy cuz he used
to write for Pryor
now how did you look him up uh it was
just New York like I knew I knew
Caroline's on Broadway because I was a
huge fan of Dave Attell and like the New
York circuit like that and that was kind
of how I started getting into comedy was
just listening to comedy albums and yeah
I my mom was in town and she was like
what do you want to do and I said we
should go to a comedy club and he
happened to be there
he was the last he was the last night
yep yeah exactly midnight show so I was
like well if we can stay up why don't we
go see this cuz this guy used to write
for Richard Pryor he was on Chappelle's
Show he's he's really funny on the show
let's go watch him and it it was
otherworldly like I don't think I'll
ever be that [ __ ] good like walking
out of there I was like how the [ __ ]
does somebody do that
I just I couldn't believe cuz he just
sat in the chair he sat in the chair and
he had the microphone and he just he
just sat there and he looked at
everybody and it was so personal yeah it
felt like we were just learning his
house or on his porch just and he was
talking about people you know it it
changed me it was like this guy's making
us see everything and it's it's so
different like being in the room with
with Mooney was nothing like like what
you saw on TV because even when walked
out like I was with my [ __ ] mother
and my mother looked at me and she's
like I've never seen anything like that
never you know cuz she she grew up on
the plains and and we're you know that
that's what so when she saw Paul Mooney
and then later on she actually got to
meet him cuz I was like we would ask if
we could stay and watch his show we you
know when you were answering phones and
he oh yeah brother whatever you gotta do
and he just [ __ ] walked down and we'd
sit in the back and we just watch him
and to watch him work was like how many
times did you watch it like karolides um
I total it was four and what did you
think the had you been on stage yet know
what you're thinking about it oh yeah
watching his salivate and watching it
watching him do it it looked so [ __ ]
easy you're like look at how relaxed he
is look at how personable he is like
yeah it's it's so easy and then you
[ __ ] do it and you're like well like
and not just like an hour but he would
do like an hour and 20 and I went there
you never knew when he was done like I
don't think he knew when he was done he
just he would just get up and he [ __ ]
water was no clothes no there was it was
just like oh I gotta get out yeah yeah
it was just like that yeah I guess it's
gonna bore me he pick up his bag before
I gotta go goodnight that would be one
black person the only everything else
you [ __ ] just on the ball man and he
would just walk off the [ __ ] stage
with his little bottle of champagne
he would get the mitchell-lama champagne
yep he wouldn't go on stage unless he
had a [ __ ] bottle of champagne now
well how long did it take you to get on
stage after you saw up all morning uh
when I came to LA so now you're in New
York how long I was in New York for four
years and you didn't get out of stage at
all I got on like once or twice it was
nothing that I could actually say oh
look I doing stand-up it was I gotta try
this when I get it where did you go it
was somewhere in Queens I lived on
Ditmars in Steinway and there was some
Chinese Bistro that had a [ __ ] open
mic and literally he just stood like on
a box and it was like okay and they were
let me point it you like do go I need to
[ __ ] do it and did people were eating
and they were annoyed that you were
[ __ ] in there and the mic you know
the mic you could barely hear it so you
speaking to it and they turn it up and
to be too loud it was [ __ ] it was
miserable any dream I had doing stand-up
in the or I was like this is [ __ ]
awful I will never do this shaving every
I went back to New York I was like I
don't know about this it took me nine
what's that was a beating that was
emotion for you there for years you pick
up you come here know what then a buddy
was doing a farewell show and he was
moving to Boston and he's like hey I
know you've done stand-up before he's
like do you wanna on stage I'll give
three minutes and it was a I think was
it flappers so I was like huh let me
think about and he's like well think
about so I remember when the [ __ ] that
was but I went up and I did I end up
doing five and it went really [ __ ]
well what really happened was I was I
was waiting to go up I was nervous and
Whitney Cummings had walked in and she's
like hey I was wondering if I could do a
drop-in and they were like okay when do
you want to go I'll go this I'll go here
and it happened to be I had to follow
her and I was pissed and I was like guys
I I can't [ __ ] do this like it and
they're like dude just don't don't worry
about it we'll put one guy in front of
you and I was like I alright fine [ __ ]
it
so she goes on and she [ __ ] crushed
she crushed guy went on he crushed and
then they threw me on and I don't know
what what compelled me to do it but I
just looked at everybody I was like well
I'm [ __ ] sorry I go what what do you
want from me then I go I'm gonna [ __ ]
up here trying to make you guys laugh
what do you want and I looked at one
girl like you're kind of cute
and that that changed it like that for
some reason that one the room over and I
started ragging on Whitney Cummings
because I was like why the [ __ ] did she
have to pick tonight I was like she's
brilliant why did she pick tonight
though and I was like [ __ ] her and I did
that and everybody started laughing and
I it was funny because like I saw her
and I was like oh my god I [ __ ] love
you I like now it's comedy don't worry
about I thought it was funny it got the
crowd and that that was what was amazing
was it was like okay so I did well well
enough to come back and then it was just
[ __ ] bomb after bomb after bomb it
was yeah after you win the three
thousand come back and it's like yeah
Fogg win three thousand and he give them
90 mm that's Las Vegas that's comedy do
you know why you're sitting in this room
with us tonight
I don't I don't want the [ __ ] people
that really really really makes me laugh
anymore I started going to the fourth
wall to support my friend Lee and I saw
you one night on stage I didn't bring
you here I did not say anything about
gay or anything
you've my respect for you as his
accounting but since we're talking about
him who open up that door because you
also raised in Colorado which I was in
Colorado in 83 and it wasn't cool to be
talking about Adam and Steve
you know the family you could just talk
about Adam and Steve in Colorado I know
about it in saying I'm hip and I was
cracking in the gay community but you
know you can't just say that 1983 in a
cowboy bar although those Cowboys are
the biggest [ __ ] they'd love to get
their dick sucked when they get three
beers and them don't let anybody suck
they bow and then they'll call you a
[ __ ] an x-man you [ __ ] Manor yeah and
then you'll say you didn't call me a
blini when I was swallowing the jizz
last night he's lying
I was drinking 3.2 beer I got [ __ ] if
I didn't know I didn't even know he was
being item over by mistake that they're
[ __ ] crazy
tell me I'm lying tell me I'm lying
there like I've been all over Colorado
I'll go visit and I'll turn on my
grinder and I'm like Jesus Christ like
they're all over the [ __ ] place but
they never have a Facebook no no Craig
Colorado all those all those those
businessmen of those towns are dying to
get [ __ ] and then you do have to do a
crime and they go to jail and Kansas
City they just go over to Lou they go
right over in Canyon City to the gay
wing and now they have an excuse well I
belong to him no you always belong to
somebody does it know it yet you just
didn't [ __ ] know it
Colorado do you want to be gay anymore
prison that's where they bust you out
finally once you come out you come out
you going [ __ ] Lee you come out and
you know the same for the talk [ __ ] oh
yes it's [ __ ] when I lived in
Colorado and it was wrong but don't they
like it's not gonna be just gay people
having like fun sex in prison if your
isn't gonna be like what kind they you'd
only want like the guys
well that's what you want you want dirty
dicks and you know no there's two types
of gay people there's three types of gay
people like there's three types of gay
guys there's some guys that love hookers
and though either hookers [ __ ] no
crack there's people who share their
wives there's different strokes for
different folks Lee that's what makes
the world unique yes sir progressive
53:55 will you I'm gonna do when I was
eight penis somebody asked if I wanted
around the world the first time like a
hooker talk like a guy told me there you
go and getting around the world I was
petrified you know the way Lee gets
about other bulls like when they call
them up and Tom wanna do heroin same
thing when you when somebody would talk
to me about I'm doing it around the
world like are you [ __ ] crazy what
does that mean you're gonna lick my ass
lick my balls and try to make out with
me that's not gonna happen even if I
take 20 showers you know why because if
you'd better with me you'd better with
20 animals you know say you've done it
with 20 animals so what do you like
[ __ ] what was that when I was young
the dog the Catholicism how was it just
about to tell Eric this that guys let's
be honest from the [ __ ] zero grade to
5th grade I drank the juice
I was all in I would not I was not gonna
let a priest molest me when I drank the
juice let's be honest I believed in
Jesus I believed in this holy spirit I
believed yeah I went to my buddy and
going into the 5th grade a lot of [ __ ]
started happening Richard Brown Bruce
Lee died once Bruce Lee died of the form
of immigrants left so now we were free
again we didn't have a leader again in
68 when Bruce Lee came out Oh everybody
had a voice that didn't have a voice
anymore
the word bully wasn't used but it was
the same thing there was no more bullies
for immigrants some men now we had
something we had this power the other
night was Bruce Lee's 45th anniversary
Friday night that night I
it was Lee's birthday but I felt really
bad but I got home that night and they
were playing the crow on TV had like
7:30 and it messed me up so much like
they remembered that I
Fist of Fury I put on Chinese connection
it to me it's Chinese connection and can
you can you find the dojo scene and
Chinese connection I mean this is just
gonna freak you out
just pushing Doge you're saying just
nobody really understands this and I
talked about it on Rogen nobody
understands this when you're about to
see you know I was a kid like you raised
in the light at home the thing about me
is my mom was I'm not being fully clean
correct tonight my mom was we reconsider
in the late sixties a [ __ ] hag my mom did
business with a lot of gay men because
that was the drug business but this
scene right here changed America forever
Fist of Fury his first movie the third
one see they call it Fist of Fury but
it's really it got released here as the
Chinese connection and this this changed
America forever
they had just gone to his school and
said that Chinese this is when the
Chinese people were held down by the
Japanese people and they gave him a
picture and on that picture
it says sick man of Asia you never seen
this era now this changed America
forever look at his body language
[Music]
what do you want
this changed American fabric I broke out
into tears like I'm about to break into
fear right now this changed America
forever if you were black if you were
Chinese if you were any minority that
you were you selling sit right here -
your life changed this is the little guy
sticking up for the big guy
yeah yeah right oh I see okay you can
take this from me and then get out of
here so I bring a picture back to your
house whenever you are ready I'll take
on any Japanese you this changed America
forever this the clash with movies you
never heard the word bully watch what
this dummy says to Bruce Lee so you'll
want to see how good you are then you
must be tired of living well be fine
alone or all together it'll just take me
to show you just changed America guys
because the first one wasn't that
publicize
[Music]
I'm watching this Friday night tears are
coming out of my eyes I'm thinking about
my childhood what I thought life was
[Music]
this kick changed the history of [ __ ]
America
watch this kicked Eric it's perfect over
lights up everybody the movie theater
went crazy when this happened right here
this was the introduction of you're
never gonna [ __ ] with me again this was
it this is 1971 that's it
we had a voice now this was the
commercial Eric you lose your mind are
you [ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me and I know we've discussed
this before right now you can see it
just look at this but this is the best
watch this guy's watch this right watch
this was this double punch BAM who
orchestrated now watch this
this is the best watch his hand as he
flies over
watch this this is the best thing I've
ever seen
I think catches till the other night he
throws with two dummies then they kick
him in the back watch what he does the
row when he picks up boom boom with his
hand and he's got a pair of new chucks
and America is a complete different
[ __ ] country right now if you're
[ __ ] eight years old you're at the
movie theater losing your minds about
the blow-up this is they repeated the
same thing they're like go I think he
started all over again look at shitty
blood pellets it didn't matter right
there that was it everybody the movie
they just left what the [ __ ] was this
look at those eyes nobody said [ __ ]
anymore after they saw this musi they
were like that's a mistake
look at them whackin people for no
reason
[Applause]
are you [ __ ] kidding me
do you guys understand me that this was
it I'm a Catholic kid now he breaks the
glasses these two Japanese told them
that if somebody could beat them they
eat those words
watch this these two guys actually went
to Bruce Lee's school and said if
somebody can beat us from this school
we'll eat the words watch Bruce Lee this
is it this is it you left that movie
theater you went home and challenged
your father you were like dad it's over
you're never yelling at mom again I'll
bust your [ __ ] head watch this look
at look at this look at this one here
this is when he actually at the end he
goes to the school and he walks in there
this is the last scene just like the
last one
watch he says to these [ __ ]
[Music]
on a little one medical Quinn Jim I'm
here avenge my teacher by Sifu pulls out
grande do your business
so get out I'm allowing you to leave
tower tower tower don't don't
I like it better with her being dubbed
[Laughter]
this is too much for a kid to handle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
watch this why psychic over the Hey are
you [ __ ] kidding me no more losing
her mind and I used to watch these at
the midnight fool I have made seven we
you and your buddies finding each other
in the aisles we would be drooling I
call [ __ ] sevillio pedo right and let
him tell you how crazy we used to go
watch these me him [ __ ] Mike we had
a kid Mike he had to be 24 but he
thought he was like an 11 we didn't give
a [ __ ] we let him hang with us he
punches in the stomach and [ __ ] like
that really give a [ __ ] we believe he is
like our uncle he's our uncle he's all
right listen
that's how y'all rated movies
what's all this [ __ ] this is that they
can't do this anymore
I love when people say all this negative
[ __ ] about Bruce Lee because they didn't
really know he's good for he stick to
this watch this brother
watch this though this is the goods
ready well he lives the guy up just
bitch-slap see that's the way that doing
this was this was the mentality I had as
a kid that was it
this was it there was no peanut
allergies
there was no [ __ ] kids with sensitive
ears
[Music]
that's it stands for that's what he
stands for killing babies dead he stood
for this movies about him getting
tormented in the beginning they kill his
teacher and then they [ __ ] abused him
they got this she goes to a [ __ ]
school and make a stand
this movie was supposed to be something
to happen like in 1940 in Japan Japan
how to Japanese treated to Chinese
there's one scene when he goes to the
zoo and it says you know dogs are
Chinese allowed on the war and he kicks
the [ __ ] out of some Japanese people but
some employers conversations
conversation I was a Catholic like you
Spanish house and when I got thrown in a
Catholic school I went to public school
and I started listening to Richard Pryor
and one day we had to go to catechism on
Fridays when I first got the McKinley in
the sixth grade
on Fridays you had two options you got
off on one you belong to the ecology
Club and go pick up garbage on the
street which I was not doing or you go
to catechism and walked there by
yourself which made you get high we get
a six-pack of beer we can stop at the
[ __ ] season Road bump you shoplift
look what is this this is sixth grade
I'm good in things I was all the kids
from North Bergen that would be allowed
to saw the kids from other districts
like Franklin mm-hmm and then Kennedy
school they would take buses public
transportation so they would get that
lucid one those animals and I don't
remember the priest his name and we
would go to Holy something again it's
next to a theater with George Carlin
played across the floor start Dinah
which we were talking about the other
day
and it was right there that's the name
of the name in the theaters the Park
Place but in there there's like a
Catholic
thing and we would have to go in there
for Catholic for Catholic catechism and
one day some New Jersey guy had raised
his hand and he's like father could I
ask you something how do I know what
you're telling me
[ __ ] and we started laughing make
your salary let's get the [ __ ] out when
we [ __ ] you - oh I [ __ ] you [ __ ] you do
Padre he's like saying [ __ ] you does my
[ __ ] you the rest of the kids like [ __ ]
you project like 11 of us got up the
left wall with the four star diner and I
don't that's why I've made my
confirmation when I was thirty years old
Saint Michael Center st. Michael's is in
Union City on 16th Street I used to go
there - I played see what he has both of
them but you know I was raised well with
all these Catholicism things that of
things that you're not supposed to say
and do and rules and show like this now
we have a second part to add to this
conversation which is your situation
which is you are gay so now you're
living in Colorado you're 15 years old
did you already have desires for men
well yeah at that point yeah cuz you you
start to realize it's different and it's
like okay you know you have guys that
are dating chicks they're [ __ ]
feeling girls up and all that other [ __ ]
and I mean I I tried but it was like ah
I don't know there's something [ __ ]
different if it was like yeah I don't
know and then you watch home improvement
you're like [ __ ] Jonathan Taylor
Thomas that's uh that's an
interesting-looking a guy right over
there and immediately you're like oh
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] up something's broken
and it's it's it's weird [ __ ] you're
like okay [ __ ] cuz I was I loved being
Catholic I loved it
it made sense I remember you sitting
next my grandpa Church we would eat I
remember he would he would take the host
and he would save just a little bit and
he would sneak me some because I always
wondered what that what that cracker
tasted like
he was like yeah here here and the thing
of it was was it was a we used to go on
Saturday nights and then we go eat and
that was like a big thing for him he had
like an altar of all these [ __ ]
candles and it was just something that
you know if somebody died you know you
you went you prayed for them and you did
all of that so when when that happens
you're like oh [ __ ] what what the [ __ ]
going on a candle out candles at the
house absolutely why they can before you
Ally the camp before you yeah and so you
you you don't mind me asking what
happened to your parents my mom the the
crazy thing you say that you had look at
me you're tight with your mom obviously
yeah you were raised by grandpa so he
wasn't paying bills like he I I don't
know the exact story they were together
and [ __ ] like that and what I remember
cuz I asked my mom like so what what do
you what is going on with this guy and
to be fair his family his mom and his
dad were [ __ ] great to me they they
wanted to be a part of it but what ended
up happening was he was saying like [ __ ]
like oh yeah I gotta go into work and
what he would do is he was smooth he
would go to the park and he'd get high
with his friend and my mom would have to
go to work but the thing if it was was
she'd come home and she'd find like
final notice of [ __ ] like why [ __ ] I
gave you money to pay this why he than
was paid and she kindly she finally like
followed him one day and she found out
what he was doing she fought him for
awhile and she'll talk about to this day
about when she got the courage to leave
him and what that process was like cuz
she's like every day I would move
something she's like I like if I had
like the hamper full of clothes I'd move
it to mom and dad's she's like and then
I just come in and be regular she's like
I still remember you in your little
[ __ ] your little cradle that she
would carry me around it and she's like
so every day I'd moved just a little bit
of [ __ ] and she's like and then one day
I called my brothers we got all this
[ __ ] and we left is where I don't talk
about this [ __ ] a lot like to anybody so
this if I've seemed nervous that's the
reason why no [ __ ] disease a mother
but you also speak about your
grandfather so yeah I'm just a little
not really
so maybe a mother goodtime company years
I left you a grandpa
and she came on you guys would Kindle
you you know I'm money of the judge no
no no no it's drawing a pager my it's a
different it's just I've never really
talked about your Grampa was your day
yeah absolutely love him is he still
with us no he he passed away in 97 and
then my uncle buried two he took over
and that guy [ __ ] died like two years
ago I think it is now a year and a half
ago so wanting a dad and wanting like a
father figure like you know I not to
blow smoke up your ass but like honestly
like when you start coming around on the
fourth wall it was like okay [ __ ] you
would you would say something and I
would think about it and in Berkeley in
my head I'd be like [ __ ] you know what
yeah I should try this I should I should
try this and I'd try it and it work and
be like [ __ ] how did you know that how
do you know that so I'd ask you a
question again I didn't want to [ __ ]
bother you but I'd ask you a question
again and then I get the [ __ ] out of
there
I don't know if you remembered that I'll
talk to you a little bit and I get the
[ __ ] out I don't not book-smart I don't
know about sleep or voting ourselves I'd
like that I do know about the human mind
I know I know about human compassion and
all about hustle
I know about pain I was going through a
rough time guys I was going through a
really rough time
stand up wise stand the boys I was uh
you know Bobby Lee two days ago last
night so I can't leave town cuz I was at
a precipice that something might happen
let me tell you something bro
six months ago last January last
December November I was at a precipice
of maybe having a nervous breakdown
I don't know what a nervous breakdown
consists of you know we had a podcast
here about depression and Lee started
seeing somebody in honoree and I didn't
feel those things I just felt something
was lacking that here's a guy
that I'm not blowing smoke up my ass and
we have lighter
you know I've earned everything I've
gone yes I've done movies I've done
listen it and something just didn't
taste right
I didn't know who to take it to and as
you guys know and home I'm too [ __ ]
much of a prick to gonna let psycho
therapist or psychiatrist because I
believe that we should work things out
of my home
that's what makes us stronger I think
that a piece of paper and a pen and a
lot of thought and some reefer or
whatever get you to that place to
identify your situation this so one
night is still going to the comedy store
and hanging out with Tom pop and Joe
Rogan and all these people I said I want
to do something I want to go back and
start all over again I want to do a
science experiment because I am a
walking science experiment since I got
off cocaine ten years ago that's all
I've been doing this experiment I don't
know how I got the ear so I have to
figure out the formula - how the [ __ ]
did I get here so I attacked along with
Lee and I went to the fourth wall and it
was the best thing I ever did in my life
because I got to see you guys you guys
want what I got and guess what I want
what you guys got that's that's my quote
what did you see at fourth wall I mean
because it looks like you didn't know we
were looking for because when you would
come in there it was honestly it was
fascinating who watch you watch us
because you were looking for something
and when you would you would look
because to watch you I was looking for
the fundamentals of calmly if there were
his son I was looking for the
fundamentals of comedy I wanted to come
home and get a pen and go late this is
what comedy is gonna have that pen from
you and go away this county is its
chapter one this chapter to this chapter
three this chapter four I wish I could
do that I can't do that I wanted to do
it not for you guys I wanted to do it
for myself and then pass it on to you
guys the knowledge I have gotten but I
couldn't figure it out but there but
something else happened a fat [ __ ]
shall be cute Mexican down on stage
and it made me [ __ ] laugh my ass off
about being gay
now I'm 55 and if you watch any of my
CDs and in my special any of my routines
I always have a joke about a gay person
in there because they seem so funny to
me and they were so involved in my life
man I tell a story about a my dear Motty
: you know what that was in my life and
he wasn't the first one the first real
gay man in my life was the Santeria gay
dude and he used to always say [ __ ] to
me like one day I'm gonna [ __ ] you in
the ass I was like [ __ ] 6 and he
would top it like in front of my mother
and I go you [ __ ] me in is I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up [ __ ] right like I
would [ __ ] you up in front of my god in
Spanish yeah my mama put like white
shoes on me and here we go oh this is
somebody close to her son Tony likes a
[ __ ] I'll [ __ ] you up you know
like I was [ __ ] angry my father died
and this guy would say [ __ ] to me to get
my blood gun
I killed father everybody get in Hoss
alternate hélène go hey don't be [ __ ]
look at me little [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll
[ __ ] kick your [ __ ] ass so one day
he tickled me and tickle me you [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] pick them we don't touch
me and [ __ ] and I said to him I hope you
[ __ ] die you [ __ ] [ __ ] but the
next day he died yeah and they [ __ ]
know the Santeria people took me to a
house and you better never ever ever
they start throwing coconuts you know
when you do Santeria you got four
coconuts and that's how they ask
permission and they were like you better
never ever ever wish death on somebody
again baby named you as a six year not
even by mistake not even to say that's
why I was a Spanish person when they
said you know you're number 13 I don't
understand hope
death pool I [ __ ] won this years ago
on Facebook I wrote him in Spanish no
Spanish people don't talk that way
I forgot you're right you know we don't
we know [ __ ] on death list of nothing
that's again something we don't think
about that no Spanish why people love
talking about insurance policies and I'm
leaving my piano to my kid Spanish
people don't do nothing they don't sign
the will they're like in the coma
you got a hold that coma hand and that's
when they'll sign the will come on sign
it come on so we don't have to suffer
you don't say it Spanish people don't be
dying then they'll [ __ ] won't sign no
no real Jews I've known for like 15
years where everything is my mom and dad
show me oh yeah they call me when they
move it [ __ ] Forest Lawn they they
have plans yeah a lot of Jewish people
in Forest Lawn
they have like they've owned their own
their burial plots for like 50 years I
bet yeah that's bad luck I'll lose some
money just put me in the I like my uncle
they put him in the yard he's back there
for years fifteen thousand to bury
somebody put him in the [ __ ] yard can
you imagine I just take somebody on put
some powder on please tell me there's
bury bodies buried in yards in New
Jersey I'm gonna say that I can't wanna
[ __ ] nobody knows nobody knows
nothing here just talk I'm just talking
to you from the [ __ ] army but okay so
I go to the fourth war and I'm looking
to the answer to my problems I'm looking
number two I'm going through something
I'm not feeling well every night about
five o'clock I started feeling [ __ ]
shitty something wasn't right I started
taking blood tests and piss tests and it
was something my stomach and I didn't
know what the [ __ ] it was I started
drink kombucha so I just had a lot of
[ __ ] called room I had and Netflix was
starting to put the process together so
I wanted to go back to basics so I
started going to the fourth wall to
watch hoping makers in their most
primitive form
I liked the fourth wall because it made
you sit there and watch other comics
that's what that's what really lured me
to that and if you signed up or family
you got to sit in here for the whole
[ __ ] hour and watch your
buddy and it forced me I love watching
Kali but I also want to laugh as soon as
I sit down I want to laugh
I don't want rehearse [ __ ] I don't want
[ __ ] that you practice in the mirror and
I want you to react to the room
whatever happens that's what I'm looking
to see my favorite thing in the world is
getting high and if I have a ten fifteen
spot at the store I'll go at 9:15 and
sit in the back of the room and watch
those comments and learned so I went in
the fourth wall to learn but the biggest
less had learned two things in the
fourth wall I learned that what it was
to feel like you guys I made myself feel
like you guys yeah and it backfired it
[ __ ] my head up because I don't need
to feel like that again but I also got
to see you and I've been digging a lot
about you lately
because the problem my Netflix special
was that I wasn't me and I watch you on
stage and right now you're a breath of
fresh air to me [ __ ] because you do
calmly there's only two gay dudes that
I've seen and I've seen a lot of gay
guys do comedy I hate talking about
Spanish timely and black Connolly and
Jewish Connolly I hate that [ __ ] but in
the game world of you're a gay man
there's only two guys that I've seen go
up there with balls of steel as a gay
man and that's you and this guy ian's
was Santa Barbara who had open for me in
New York which was a trip because the
first land of Gotham it was Gotham now
Gotham is a place with his fights people
get it last someone will redeem Delray a
lady picked up a table and threw it this
poor little gay guy lives in the he's
helping book the room in Orange County
now so if you guys want to do it let me
know
we will three of us to do it together
and he's booking this room down to
Orange County and I used him and he
would move to New York he wanted to give
I saw him in Santa Barbara I worked in
Santa Barbara and I could see he made
when you're gay and you're white and you
make people uncomfortable you're my guy
mmm-hmm you're my guy that's what I want
to see I want to see a guy go move
that means mentally is his mental his
you made him so uncomfortable that his
brain told him to move his [ __ ] so
you can get to it so if he's sitting
this way with his girlfriend like
rubbing her hand he'll [ __ ] slow
he'll lock and load that ass because
that's what I want to see that's real
calmly if you're gay man if you're gonna
go up there and talk that Beverly Hills
[ __ ] to impress them and this guy is
amazing and trying to be captain Griffon
and drag I ain't taking the [ __ ] ride
with you I want you to tell me about
your [ __ ] fears tell me what's going
on in your world and that's the first
time I saw you you know you did a bit
about caldo gay bar and some guys
something dick in a tent and there was a
fistfight and I'm [ __ ] in the back
house and then the second one you told
is one of the best written jokes
if I have a sit here and write the ten
best written jokes and made me laugh you
know Joseph sincerely made me laugh hi
my name is Charlie Hill used to be
fountain but I'm shortened it you know
Charlie Hill is the Indian you know from
the store the first time I heard they're
the same my name is Charlie Hill I
shortened it from Mountain Dog I almost
fell off my chair okay as dumb as that
[ __ ] joke is well I heard Rodney
Dangerfield somebody posted to Rodney
joke yesterday on Facebook and he goes I
get no respect I ain't wanted a diet and
backfired I went on the rice diet I
didn't lose any weight but every half
hour
I had an iron shirt I [ __ ] lost it
though I [ __ ] lost it I love all
great jokes but a great bit a great bit
Rogen's really greatest bits of all time
is Rogan when the chicks in Texas and in
the concert Nicole Smith that's one of
the greatest bits of all plant like bro
I was such a great and brilliant bit
that Mitzi sure told the stop dude
these people couldn't follow it like
that it was how brilliant of a bit and
Nicole Smith was once he married the old
guy who looks like father he wasn't got
himself a Kentucky Fried hooker oh my
god
till this day I still laugh at those
[ __ ] jokes and the joke about him
like you know why do you only one of
those joke quite well because somebody
told me that you can see a woman's [ __ ]
for a dollar I'm like awesome I'm like
Joey
you can see a woman's [ __ ] for a dollar
don't blame me I can see your [ __ ] for
nickels
I [ __ ] bat he says that type of [ __ ]
I love jokes
you know [ __ ] Richard Pryor the
[ __ ] meets Dracula are you [ __ ]
crazy
like who's smoking pot we gotta think of
a billion I saw this [ __ ]
inhaler like dragon that's right what
imagination like what about it but your
big undertaking the harem home know is
one of the funniest things because at
the end like I told you beginning of the
show I have no reason to blow smoke up
your ass the twist at the end which I
will not reveal is one of the most
brilliant things and if you write that
joke out and some reason to go for a
writing sample you just go like this
with that joke don't ask you are you gay
this is about me [ __ ] this is something
happen to me and then you go oh you want
another one
I'm a table man I gotta blow the guy in
the tent oh you want another one about
the guy [ __ ] the guy with the ball in
his mouth when you said that one that
night I was losing myself because people
will not say that [ __ ] look at half the
people at the fourth wall what bothered
me the
let me give some hold on one second let
me get some shots before we go into this
real quick my group my new sweetheart on
Facebook the hottest chick on Facebook
latisha Katan I love you
you dual Jewish Palo Rican [ __ ]
Savage she's Jewish but yeah she's
[ __ ] Savage John Joyce my man Dennis
Rice Kash Donovan Quinton Paige
Mathew Schneider John Rizzi Stewart
Fleming Robert Reed Jake Tapper hoon and
my man rip Ripley you bad [ __ ]
don't forget me and Kato be in Salt Lake
City walking around Thursday Friday
Saturday but I'll be at the Kansas City
improv [ __ ] August 9th to the 11th
and I'll see you [ __ ] dead with
Dean Dell Rizzi you filthy [ __ ]
animals and don't forget I'll be in
Huntsville Alabama Nashville Zanies at
the end of the month in August we'll
burn that bridge when we get there right
now that's where that's all I said you
bad [ __ ] anyway so now you're 15
you don't see yourself in Colorado as
know it I I don't even and the thing of
it was is that I played football like I
came from a wrestling family they loved
like my cousin the uncle that raised me
he's he's the head wrestling coach and
he took state and everything and we're
like brothers we look we look a lot
alike he's got a wife he's got three
beautiful kids and we look just like
each other and the funny thing is is
when I go down there I'll have grinder
on and they're like oh [ __ ] is that
coach on [ __ ] guy and like I always
got to tell them like hey just so you
know this is who I am because they love
an anonymity in [ __ ] Colorado because
they can't be gay so what cracks me up
about it is is I always got to tell them
hey I'm not I'm not your [ __ ] coach
so don't don't what did you have in
counties in Colorado before you went to
New York or were your first encounters
in New York because New York is a hell
of a place to be gay yeah if I was
Begay that's the capital no that's what
you write usually right that's that's
what I saw it I thought father said it
in front of me
yep and it was very interesting to see I
saw the growth like I said that story on
Comedy Central I stir him and Martin
missing a tooth some weeks some we see
come over you have a black eye some we
see got stabbed this is what it wasn't
eco friendly to be de 1972 73 75 it
wasn't eco friendly people two men were
not walking down the street hard in a
hand it would take 50 yards before
somebody pulled over kicked him in the
stomach got back in the car who they're
gonna call the cops are getting good
help it was when I still told Bootsie
ledee yeah he has to because of the gay
world is some crazy people to [ __ ] yes
crazy people to it's the old adage you
don't [ __ ] with you know I watch that I
love all the FX series and then hundra
cunanan one wasn't something disturbing
that's the guy that killed Rashad she
that started like you know he was
[ __ ] nuts nuts and you know in my
many years of doing drugs you know and
when I was younger the big circle to get
the leash rugs like it you get coke from
anybody but when you want to delete
cocaine there was a gay lady a lesbian
when you wanted when I bought all those
quaaludes the best quaaludes I bought
was from a lesbian girl her brother was
a gangsta real mafia in like Wikipedia
and everything still I'm not gonna tell
you their name but I used to bike
quaaludes and my sister I was simple
they were mafia quavers you know there
was a time when to get the best coat you
had to go to the meat market that place
I told ya the one gay bar with the three
floors ramrods the ramrods and that's
why I saw them use the Russian love yeah
they would use Roger Gress aggressive
names bullet grammar they would have
poppers they would break poppers
absolutely the make out with each other
and I would sit there go what the [ __ ]
is going on
but I never looked down on it you know I
never it wasn't for me to judge and
that's that's a thing in Colorado it was
it was one of those things where I
didn't dare come out and like I think
everybody kind of knew but it was one of
those things where it's like okay we're
not gonna talk about it let's let's not
talk about it I'll play football I was
an all-conference football like a
failure react to it I moved in New York
and met somebody and I came back and my
mom was surprised she was like okay and
she's like I I honestly didn't know I'm
like really and she's like I had
questions but I I took you at your word
and then like cousins and stuff like
that people that I was close to and told
them they were like why didn't you ever
tell us you could have told us and it
was almost like they were mad that you
didn't tell them cuz that's it's a weird
thing because you really don't know how
somebody's gonna react
cuz the thing about like you talked
about honesty in comedy and [ __ ] like
that people don't like when I say [ __ ]
on stage like other other gay comics
I've had other gay comics scold me for
saying that word I grew up around that
word you say them when they come up to
you it's called you I I listen to him
because I know it's coming from a place
of pain I know that and they're like you
you know you could do that joke so much
better and in my yeah that day don't
work that funny no you can't [ __ ] is a
word cuz it's a word not because it's
gay I don't use it at all and the gay
[ __ ] to have no beef at all would game
it like I am no abuse at all out of
respect for gay men that's it that's the
gay salute you know I'm saying I got no
beef oh I love this I put my hand he was
real cool like it still blowing Italy
he's to hold on I like how he blames me
for the Flies and the bugs listen to me
I always blamed I always take
responsibility for the farts when
I comes in here he chases your [ __ ]
fat little [ __ ] you know option nope
I was in here with Ralphie I've been
here with eight or seven people because
he flies on your neck before they know
if they've called me the next day said
why is it bees and animals on Lee's neck
all the time this is a filthy [ __ ]
alimony he said [ __ ] humus and you
don't bathe you only bet you do oh my
god the only bathe in the morning you
supposed to bake quite before you come
down as far as eight o'clock you take a
shower I don't want that grease coming
through your neck all day long I'm a
greasy neck yes you do when that Sun
shines on your [ __ ] neck okay I'm
doing it son yeah the three feet you
walk today it makes that I smell it
sometimes I could smell your neck that's
why it's not my neck because I'm getting
a beautiful smells Wayne worse no it
don't rot I blow that way towards you
and keep talking I have another one
percolating that's gonna knock your
[ __ ] wig off this will give you more
hair than [ __ ] for him because this
will grow you smell what's coming out of
my ass next I wake up tomorrow you'll be
a Beatle you understand you're like one
of the Beatles you can say what I
believe is a General John letter
so it's my hair gonna smell like your
[ __ ] who knows I don't know how is that
we did you smoke I had everything in
there
so forget about [ __ ] mama over here
let me ask you a question so tonight
we're out there one night I mean when
you I watched you
I watched you a cup of mine so I'm like
this disguise [ __ ] hilarious disguise
he's in a different league and nobody
knows because he's hidden up here
they're forcing him to hide but that
ends tonight and it was funny because
then you came outside you spoke to me
about Paul Mooney and if you know
anything about me that's the education
that I got I got the education of Paul
Mooney and that's what I forgot what I
shot my Netflix special and that's what
I forgot when I went up to the fourth
wall and I forgot it again I told Bobby
Lee and I told this to
there's a couple people that Jim Norton
said something once that kind of
bothered me he said that he doesn't
watch other comic specials and I thought
that was kind of arrogant and I [ __ ]
got it why he doesn't watch other comic
special because it takes your mind away
that lets you think you know I'm really
concerned about the mind I'm always very
concerned about the mind and what goes
on in it and would stand up we have to
be ourselves the biggest thing that
people say the most is be yourself be
yourself we never know what that I never
know what that meant I don't know what
that means I have no idea would be your
cellmates you know that means foregoing
me to go up then talk about what I do
best what I tell me on the phone when
I'm on the phone when we and he's laughs
and then we're doing other things that's
what I do best
not when I try to be a witty writer that
will ain't trying to be somebody I'm not
yeah you have to be who you are you my
friend on stage at the five-year mark
have found yourself which is truly
amazing you know it's just truly amazing
you know once this special airs I'm
gonna get more dates and I'm gonna take
you out in a couple days just so the
world sees you and they're not gonna
like me at first you're gonna come up to
me and go these people in this [ __ ]
Club do not like me but I don't want you
to give a [ __ ] because that's the same
education I had from Rogan they didn't
like me and after a while I knew they
weren't gonna like me so I went out
there balls to the wall and it taught me
something different about Tommy they're
not gonna like you but if I stick around
well enough you don't [ __ ] like me I
got an old adage you may not suck my
dick today but you're gonna suck it got
a boyfriend and you love my no no but
you got one weakness you do cocaine and
I said play that cocaine so one night
some more where you're gonna suck my
[ __ ] helmet because I'm gonna show
whether they can catch you off guard
that was then I'm saying now I don't
want my dick sucked I'm married it's the
truth you know when you leave the house
in the morning
you have that type of in town when you
go on state you go they read of a suck
my dick what I'm gonna suck my dick
you're saying like they're either gonna
laugh or they gonna suck my dick that's
what Joe Diaz is and I forgot until I
saw you and the other night when I watch
Tennyson on that CNN comedy Sean right
that's who [ __ ] I called him
immediately and I said we gotta get him
on the show cuz now I got the hook to
get you on the show because I just don't
like putting people on the show you know
people complain a man put me on your
show you got no reason we're gonna put
you on the show there's no where you're
gonna go with it you your prime you're
ready you're ready to go out there and
do 20 minutes every [ __ ] week and let
these people see and you're gonna go
through some oh they gotta love you in
the Bible bumps you don't say that's
you're gonna you never [ __ ] wanna
quit that's that's the thing of it
though is like I went to a friend's
graduation in Lawrence Kansas and all of
his buddies were around and I was I was
making gay jokes and they were laughing
because the thing about it is I don't
get booked on little shows around West
Hollywood I don't and I'll I think a lot
of that is because I say [ __ ] or I I
it's just it's it's a different kind of
perspective that's not to say that's the
only reason like it's just it's strange
though like I don't know how I would do
for a gay crowd that was just strictly
built for gay but I was talking with my
friend and he's like you don't want that
and I realized that that's that's what
the truth is is I want to be able to go
to Greeley and I want to walk into a
room where it's mostly straight people
they they don't know anybody game they
don't know anything like that and if I
can walk in there and [ __ ] get them
then that means the [ __ ] world to me
that that's that's where comedy is you
know we do when we did that detox center
it's like okay that's where they [ __ ]
need comedy cuz it's like holy [ __ ] like
that that room was just so dour and it's
like [ __ ] I don't even want to [ __ ]
be here but then we start riffing
we start joking about you know what we
did when we were drunk and how [ __ ] up
it was and they start laughing a little
bit and it just it feels better and
that's that's what I listen to your
[ __ ] laugh compilation when I get up
out of bed in the morning because I
don't want to [ __ ] go to work I don't
want to [ __ ] go to work I I get up I
have to drag myself all this into
[ __ ] I'll listen to church all this
in the [ __ ] old Opie and Anthony
should all listen to anything to get me
the [ __ ] out of bed and do my job so
that I can go to fourth wall and try
something that happened or try a bit
that might work
no I [ __ ] it's it's all I that's all
I live and breathe now it's like [ __ ]
you know I I I wanted to put myself in
situations where they were [ __ ] they
were tough cuz it was like you know the
first time I ever went to the store real
quick I gotta tell you this I was like
okay this is gonna happen I'm excited
cuz you always hear about it so I went
there and Doug Stanhope was gonna be
there and I was like okay I'm gonna
[ __ ] break my cherry on Stanhope this
is amazing and I remember standing there
and the door guys were come on this way
come on let's go they weren't you know
they weren't mean but it wasn't like a
jovial hey welcomed it was like come on
let's go I was like alright and I
remember when I walked in it was cold
and it was [ __ ] black and it was dark
and those neon lights were on and
blaring was when the levee breaks Led
Zeppelin and I was [ __ ] scared I
don't know why I got really anxious and
I was like oh [ __ ] this is this is a
crazy dark place and I sat down and
[ __ ] Stanhope just be crushed like I
it was amazing and then I walked out of
there and I just I walked like for an
hour and a half and it was just like
what the [ __ ] was that and that's why I
like the store when you talk about the
store and you're like yeah I'm going up
at ten I I went there two nights ago
with my budding we were just sitting in
the back and I was watching these paid
regulars because everybody's in Montreal
a lot of people in Montreal and I was
like I'm gonna see the real newer paid
regulars and I wanted to see that and
when you watch him it's like you're
still learning [ __ ] and I'm like [ __ ]
man it was the first time every day I
was like I want I want that bomb in the
Oh R I [ __ ] want that because I got
to do that like [ __ ] a thousand times
in order to do well because the thing
that you don't realize is when you go up
in the main room or you go up in the oh
are you [ __ ] crush you do and I look
I'm here I may be telling you yes Oh
bleep yeah you in it's it I I compare it
to this you watch that new Elvis
documentary yes on HBO absolutely the
thing that that got me about cuz I was
like I never got into Elvis because I
grow I don't know really and I looked
and watching that guy perform so I was
like oh he's got the voice but it's the
[ __ ] performance when he would throw
out his arms he would [ __ ] do that
[ __ ]
and he would just he had this [ __ ]
attitude you have that when you walk on
stage it's it's it it's the whole field
yeah and it is this fear I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is because when you
walk out there like I said Mooney has
it's it's this [ __ ] that's where I
got attitude
yeah it's this attitude get mad at Lee I
get mad every day of Lee because Lee
thinks about [ __ ] I told him two weeks
ago I told him if you don't get rid of
that you're never gonna be a good time
gotta get rid of that that [ __ ] that you
have until you don't get rid of that
you're gonna take it to a certain level
you got to take that safety then let it
go in all aspects of your life
it's really weird like you think about
it you're like what the [ __ ] is he
saying what the [ __ ] was so weird I was
I was scared of everything when I got
the family and the more I did calm me
the more that [ __ ] [ __ ] I had to get
rid of like I had to get rid of it and I
got the prison and I had done a thousand
things before you had to count me but
that was still such a [ __ ] little
mama's boy when I got into comedy
I thought there's gonna be a perfect
world but I knew for me to get where I
was going it couldn't be perfect because
this is perfectly it's not but I'm
better off than sitting at the fourth
wall and doing five shows at the fourth
wall sleeping in my van
do you know I'm saying oh [ __ ] yeah so I
knew that this to be perfect
there was gonna be some years of a
profession and that means you have to
get out of your comfort zone you don't
like eat this Gotti that I will do a
[ __ ] what you like to watch you know
what
because while you read that you're gonna
think of a joke why are you doing all
that nasty disgusting stuff you're
thinking a joke when you take your dick
out of a woman is she [ __ ] farts next
to her you like this is life you cannot
be a comic without life experiences
every time I go to a fourth wall I get
angry as [ __ ] for two things the comics
touch the mic and then they take their
phone out like the answer to their
[ __ ] problems it's on this stupid
[ __ ] phone
show me one stand-up who looks on their
[ __ ] phone for you to become a good
stand-up you're gonna get rid of that
phone because you gotta live life you
gotta see every
[ __ ] picture you gotta see every
[ __ ] picture if you're too busy doing
this you can't do it you're gonna be
limited to this to be a green light I
love when people [ __ ] call me [ __ ]
and call me names and call me a [ __ ]
the life I had I laugh because I was
forced by my mother dying I was forced
to live a different life you think I
like sitting on a [ __ ] bar is that
what you think I love doing drugs I can
do drugs to the cows come home but you
will not see me in a [ __ ] bar and a
booth after my Johnny Bananas drinking
bottle service you'll never see me would
you would never see me when I was 25
either I like doing drugs in my own
house yeah I don't like people saying me
weak yeah why would you want to see
somebody see you all week you know Joe
Rogan in the 20-year relationship he
called me out a couple one night and I
couldn't even make eye contact with once
at this car I kept looking straight told
me he wasn't coming down so I went off
early and also these show that I was
like god damn it he goes come on get in
the car let's go for a ride and then I'm
gonna call coked out with the window
open when he had a Supra smoking
cigarettes my [ __ ] trailer might make
my jaw stop
you know embarrassed I wasn't fun was I
never wanted him to see me on coke he
knew I did coke that's fine well I never
ever want them to see me do coke cuz it
was my weakest point you know I lived ah
we got in this conversation about
drinking about you getting out of like
safety all this [ __ ] why break your
balls did you you can't become a comic
if you eat three times the sushi Jean
I'm saying yeah you can't become a good
comic if you eat shrimp tuna and spicy
tuna you have no life experiences you
have no this is why I'm appreciative
that Lee's going through what he's going
through now because you guys saved him
he was on the couch every night
listening some chick talking about bugs
stupid [ __ ] TV shows he was behind it
he was behind it
he was really buying into it had a
problem he didn't know how lucky was he
got rid of her and started his own life
and I don't can't be the stand-up not
that's not the reason why I love him I
love him that he's free and he's dirty
and he's seen the world for what he is
yeah but you can't give me a good
stand-up you know when you told me you
went to the gay bar with him that night
I almost ripped off on the good side I
was a jerk-off coming my hand and throw
it in my face like the priest rose it
when you're a young kid they destroy it
in your face yeah because that's how
happy you made me that you went to a gay
bar cuz you did something just the fact
they did something you don't have a
friend that comes in does coke I don't
do cocaine I don't want to do coke but
he's gonna have to do it one time if
he's gonna be a good time just not
enough to get my heart attack just to
taste it so he gets his dick sucked or
something you know you know this is a
life that we live I don't want you to be
a junkie I've never won in d20 edibles
but I don't want him to go out with a
bunch of comics one night and they'd
give an edible they [ __ ] him up just him
now I gotta go [ __ ] somebody yeah yeah
so I'll [ __ ] him up and I'll take care
of him cuz he knows I take care of him
yep so nobody can [ __ ] with him when I
give him a [ __ ] animal tranquilizer
and he don't know what he tells me that
he fell asleep with his clothes on you
know saying I got him I got him
he took it from me you know I'm saying
like you know but then like that's a wit
cuz you when you said a couple minutes
ago I need to stop doing things I've
been thinking about it I don't forget
what you when you're like right
you got enough this [ __ ] off but you
also tell me to not to not be as dirty
as that but I don't think I'm that
drugged want you to be clean the
beginning so you the first two years you
should be clean just to learn how it is
you don't look like a guy that's gonna
talk about eating your ass youie this no
then why would you talk about don't do
you [ __ ] people from the breakfast have
you ever [ __ ] somebody in the ass and
come in the face no then how you gonna
talk I don't okay then what do you talk
about not having sex you told me even
Lenny like don't be that dirty Oh
do don't do it like I did it I'm a loser
it took me twenty seven years and it
took me fifteen you follow I'm trying to
say to you it took me twenty seven but I
could've done in 15 if I would have done
these same facts that I'm telling you to
[ __ ] up ahead let me shut your [ __ ]
mouth and do your first two years clean
and at the end of two years then come
back to me and I'll go okay this year
you're gonna work improv but I've never
done improv I've never gone to the
ground I really don't give a [ __ ] the
first time I see you do a joke on the
road I will fire you you will sing go
home on your own dime you will not do a
[ __ ] joke in front of me I want you
to go up there and say hello how are you
people tonight will you do for a living
I'd start right there you can go
backwards and that's what you do for you
and then I'm gonna make you break that
habit and every time I see you talking
to the audience I'm gonna make you get
off the throw some magic a [ __ ] yo-yo
a rock a [ __ ] corner until I cut you
until I cut you that means now but guess
what by the end of five years I'm gonna
give you an education I'm gonna teach
you how to be a recession at some point
I'm gonna teach you how to be dirty for
two I'm gonna teach I'll do improvise
for one I'm gonna teach you how to stop
improvising cuz it's a bad [ __ ] habit
but I want you to know it I don't want
you have cigarettes on you know you
don't smoke now I don't want you to
smoke cigarettes but I do want you to
smoke a cigarette I don't want you to
smoke cigars but I do want you to smoke
a cigar do I want you to suck average
[ __ ] it would be nice if I got a picture
self-inquiry but I don't want you to
suck his [ __ ] try to enjoy that you went
with him to a gay bar and experienced
this and I enjoy that he loves you as
much as he does and I know that he would
never let nothing happen when you tell
me you with him at 2:00 in the morning I
know the worst thing that could happen
is you could fall asleep and wake up
with your pants on backwards and he has
his little sore and he's sleeping
dreaming with a smile on his face like I
went to that when I went to the gay bar
I was so overwhelmed in there you have
to be I'm overwhelmed and then I you see
me hanging on gay bars now I wouldn't
walk into a [ __ ] gay bar today if you
pay because I don't talk about it was
raining and I turned the wrong way out
of the bar so for 10 minutes I thought
that my car was stolen and I was gonna
have to tell you
got stolen out of the game bar care to
come back to man [ __ ] bar like if you
can't happen to me every time nothing
happens to me for 29 years and then I
meet Joey and let everything bad happens
I never got once died
I gotta started coming back on the dam
apart use a clean comedy one year that
provides comma one more year of clean
comedy and then you can talk about sex
but then you're on the road in the car
so you're meeting different people
you're without Joey you're in Montana
you're in my oming you're in [ __ ]
hi-de-ho you're gonna get notices that
will tell you don't curse cause this is
a Mormon audience tonight
what are you doing they tell you that in
advance they just booked you Lee they
booked you they go away you're gonna
work August 7th to the 11th which is
Tuesday through Saturday right and then
the week of the gig they're gonna email
you you're gonna print it and this
wasn't pre a print down with the five
gigs and the first gigs gonna say you
can't be blue as a feature act and
you're gonna thank God Joey made me work
clean for two years is that what the
store was for you guys like a training
ground or was this just [ __ ] no no my
life was triple my training ground was
driving and tribble that's the training
ground of killers will talk to triple if
you need somebody call triple I'll call
triple for you and get you and [ __ ]
here in the car up there the winter
January with skeet iodine when you gotta
get off stage you're the only Mexican in
Idaho in this part of life they've never
seen the Mexican they touch you're funny
[Music]
you ever see that episode of Sopranos
what's uh what's this what's Elvis land
where there's no Jews and no it's happy
that's what they said you to do calmly
so first of all you gotta go up on stage
you go hi I'm Lisa I am I'm Jewish right
away you're losing half the order like
half the places where you go to the
Train they've never seen a Jew they'll
come up to you later on and touch it
Jew it's hysterical you know when I was
going through these places people had
never heard of a Cuban and I was same
dumb jokes I was like I swam in a 2x4
you know [ __ ] like that and they would
love it I would love it because that was
they the dairy the allergy of the Cuban
you know I would talk about desi on
there's the stupid [ __ ] they would love
it that was my way of I didn't know what
to do that I didn't that I had no idea
what to do you know the story yes the
store was the second part of my
education the store RK when I walked
into the comedy store was doing comedy
honestly honestly five years savagery
and three years stupidity it was my
first two years were very there's a lot
of comics in this town that I'm a comic
and they had a business card I have a
business card you know you really did
yeah I'm a comic but I would always book
these gigs but I would get to coked up
to get down there so by the time the gig
11 I would always cancel so I was
unreliable and then I went to New York
and I didn't find much in New York and
at the New York Comedy Club I kind of
got it I kind of got what it was and
then I saw something mentor at the
disbar I saw John Leguizamo performing
and that's what it all came to me it
takes you three is just for the whole
mechanism to come to you they she is
just a little combination to come to you
once it comes to you and you set your
plan on what you're gonna do that was
what I did then everything all the
negative [ __ ] that you heard all your
life went away like it all came to play
somebody told you something once and now
calmly is living that like when I went
to prison
and they did the mental evaluation and
all that that guy told me goes I kept to
ask them because all the other inmates
kept saying what did you paperwork said
I'm like I don't know and then I you
don't want to know
you got to pay your attorney to find
that that's what the feds know Bachchan
all this [ __ ] and I forget what it's
called the first week you gotta Canyon
City you a little place where they do
mental tests diagnostic diagnostic and
what the diagnostic report said was that
anything I wanted and if I wanted
something I would take it but if I
wanted something you had I would take it
you know and I remember when I came back
from Colorado and I really when I came
back from New York after doing nine
months and just getting beat up you know
nine months in New York
it's an emotional beating as a comic my
second year it was like cuz it wasn't
just the emotional bt lea has a degree
in fact the end of three years Lea
doesn't like what happens he goes back
to [ __ ] delavane he could run a
podcast division he could run a radio
store now I had no qualifications mm-hmm
Tommy was that dog I already had the
family's had two felonies great two
felonies not everybody's looking and
jumping on their way to hide Mickey
Mouse degree wasn't really gonna do that
to me once they investigated they knew
that my degree was gonna be a Mickey
Mouse so I had no options when I got it
when I got into comedy the only option
was living in a car traveling and not
answering to anybody that was all I was
good at doing was not answering to
anybody and living my own life I could
be there and I could get up at 8:00 the
more I could do all that [ __ ] but the
drugs made me unreliable you know so
when I walked into the store at the
eight year mark I didn't know it wasn't
gonna re-education if that's what you're
asking
yeah yes it was a rien and just like you
my spots were late and Paul Mooney would
come around at 12:00 fine and when I
left Seattle somebody had came up to me
one there and turned me on the album
called race when the whole that [ __ ] was
going down with OJ and Nicole Oh [ __ ]
and I could lie to you I could lie to
both he is in the audience and say that
I've known about porn warrior while I
hadn't known form when he was till 1995
and I've been to Richard Pryor since
1975 74
so I never knew Paul Mooney was when I
read a book I read some book and it
mentioned Paul Mooney and Richard Pryor
they wrote together then there was
rumors and poor moody blue Richard Pryor
he's cooked that one night and [ __ ] like
that and just you know when he walked
into the store it was like this big
legend and then I had this CD and in
those days when you had somebody's
cassette that's what I had a having to
set I took I took those are the best to
kid like I love delirious
and I loved Andrew Dice clays first
album but at that time I was listening
to the night too laughter died oh and
race those are two great comedy CDs for
the five year comic to listen sir the
first year comma can not digest those to
see these especially they're like toll
after die oh my god we listened to that
and I I was like the [ __ ] balls to do
this is insane
I I was sitting there I literally was
like there were moments where I would
[ __ ] cringe be like what the [ __ ]
that's the gift not even just a deal but
to put it out oh yeah that that was what
we were like this that's the gift to
make you go to make your Cthulhu
well Ice Age will happen have two
[ __ ] jokes I say you don't think they
ring when Catholicism Bell are you
really [ __ ] crazy are you [ __ ]
crazy do you know that the first couple
years of my life I couldn't do comedy in
front of my really really really really
good friends because I didn't want them
to know I thought this way like I would
do shows in Jersey and bomb eat dicks
bags people that never even talked to me
again these people would leave its
barest because I would freeze up in
front of them I never wanted them to
know I had those thoughts even though
you had done drugs with them and I
didn't want them to have these thoughts
I know I get that I suck in and then
when I did the I did Oh a rock bar
couple years ago I ate a bag of dicks Oh
before I started working Gotham I did
this bar Oh
called something beautiful bitter end
the bitter end
I've heard about that that the bitter is
five or six years ago
yeah did the bitter end I heard you to
semi-people down a Tuesday night and my
friends were there from the sixth grade
and I couldn't wait somewhat area I'm
trying to improvise I'm getting red in
the face
I could feel sweat beads going from the
back of my head down my back onto my
jeans it was horrible yeah I got into a
fight I'm blamed the wildest [ __ ] that
my hecklers it was me it wasn't me that
couldn't do that material in front of my
dear friends now I don't give a [ __ ]
like you I thought a lot about you well
I was shooting the special I thought
about what I wanted because everybody
kept something this is the first time
people gonna see you in other countries
and stuff so you really want to
introduce yourself you know bro I missed
the boat this is all about just being
funny don't introduce yourself I'd love
to say hello
I'll have to say goodbye I'll have to
tell you I'm gay I'd have to say I'm an
addict I love the tail with the prison
I have one job as a cop and that's to be
[ __ ] funny
yeah that's it and we get confused and I
want to brush on the show - thank you -
your face fun confusing me you under
confused me about comedy like now I know
who I am by seeing you when you're on
stage you just took Kennison that's some
people can't wait to tell you they're
[ __ ] gay in today's society
I can't wait to die I got mental illness
today everybody wants a thing they got
something when I PTSD all those years of
doing drugs and Joey gave me huh
oh I anxiety doesn't go shut your
[ __ ] mouth before you became gay
before you became a comic before I
became a felon before why didn't
anything were both men men and we have
an obligation is meant when you go up on
stage and
Catholic men especially with art it's
[ __ ] hard in the beginning work but
if you look into it what do you think
Jesus will the Apostles didn't crack
[ __ ] jokes - Jesus man the time is
that they just don't tell you in the
Bible put that if you were one of those
[ __ ] that had to go you know
Jesus what's up with the sandals okay
the [ __ ] you know you think Richard
Pryor wrote and again what would you do
if somebody actually told Jesus don't
you go down and mess with the Jews a lot
not money but I got passed out - Richard
Pryor like in the Chicago where he was
growing up in Moline Chicago where he
grew up
you know that's what it fella when you
asked met Jesus I met him on the
railroad that Bowl I told them don't go
down it don't you go down here messing
with them Jews a lot more money the
first time I heard that I had to be
tenth and I already knew what the [ __ ]
they were talking what year did the
[ __ ] crazy come out I shouldn't be
googling less it says it was released
stacks on May in May of 1974 and then
were prized in November 10th 1975
I even got some Bob Newhart in here now
even like like Cosby the himself knows
my present direction to it I [ __ ] I'll
listen to that today mitts like Jesus
[ __ ] look at this album cover that that
[ __ ] crazy
yeah like when he was on some show to
promote this mm-hm and they said I can't
do the white woman goes oh yeah say the
word finger look at this look at the
names of this the jokes I hope I'm funny
[ __ ] the sees you happy ass home by 11
black on white lifestyle The Exorcist
wino dealing with Dracula flying saucers
the back down black man white woman
[ __ ] vs. the police wino versus junkie
Richard Pryor this album is brilliant is
it something I said
eulogies shortages white people new
[ __ ] cocaine just us mudbone intro
then the sad - is mudbone little feets
when you will believes you the goodnight
kiss women a beautiful and our text for
today and then Bicentennial [ __ ]
classic this is one that I got throwing
on a rake candelas house for what oh my
god I bought this to his house black
Hollywood mudbone goes to Hollywood
Chinese restaurant acid Bicentennial
[ __ ] this is what this is it guys
hillbilly black and white woman our gang
and Bicentennial prayer this is this is
uh my [ __ ] childhood 1976 he would
release one leaves every [ __ ] year
see that's the that was let's see you
can do that because you could take these
you even take these in ten weeks nobody
would know its sides and they would just
put them together
sure would take me a month to take you
got a month to tape or [ __ ] out do
twenty minutes in you tape until we got
an hour that's it that's what I'm gonna
do from now on I'm bringing it right
back to vinyl and [ __ ] cassette I'm
not doing no more special
I'm done never again yeah yeah this
should be out in like October they told
me the generates leaves been help I did
it it you know we made a look as good as
we can it's not my best work by far you
know I wish I had more Erik Rocha the
balls are very gross in there but
somewhere along the line I got skin I
forgot who the [ __ ] I am
so just thank you for reminding me who
the [ __ ] I am and keep doing what you're
doing if the name of the Netflix thing
is degeneracy you Emily will be having
Bates on the degenerate tour 2018 2019
and that's it man you really make me
laugh if you guys out there listening
you know I don't know if you have a
webpage yeah Erik Rocha comedy calm Erik
Rocha calm be calm you know it's it's
funny that I go to cry cryotherapy and
you told me you were going to gay pride
so out of respect for you every time I
went to crowd therapy gay month I put on
Madonna burn the guy's ago why do you
listen to Madonna I think because I have
respect for Gay Pride Month they would
just look at me at the fireplace
and look at each other girl what the
[ __ ] is wrong with him so after Gay
Pride I went back the biggie warning you
know I'm saying but I'm still gonna keep
him honest with Madonna burning up like
a virgin and physical attraction tries
[ __ ] gay people crazy with me but
Madonna doesn't it people [ __ ]
bananas especially the Beverly Hills gay
community they go [ __ ] nuts it's for
they have a friend inside uh and uh and
what did she's economies not anymore
she's a drunk and I love a dealing but
we don't chat anymore cuz she's too much
of a drunk but she's really part of a
big again and she goes to pride she does
all that stuff and she introduced me to
a lot of gay guys and I like 30% of them
in Hollywood because I think that they
were doing it for all the wrong reasons
you know like I know what a gay guy acts
like
the bar you know what Tina Mariko I love
him I loved him because he used to tell
me stories about music he was Cuban and
he knew about the Ramones and [ __ ] he
had got to see the Allman Brothers he
said he saw crazy coke to one like home
yeah I would be bunny go I said it I
said he won't petty ghetto he used to
always tell me all these stories about
coke he would sell - but he'll always
gonna see the Ramones was it the Ramones
and [ __ ] like that time and CBGB's yes
he's even named Bobby's always say you
like my [ __ ] money go don't ever come
home with a story cuz I'll bust your
[ __ ] head busters [ __ ] head - but
my mother always loved Martin the fact
but Eric I got to tell you something I
just wanted to bring you on the podcast
- thank you you know you said to me one
night again back to the conversation you
said that there's a lot of comics that
don't shake your hand there's no there
was one that didn't like the the game
material I was doing and he said I'm not
shaking your [ __ ] hand what you just
said it's disgusting was he gay or
straight he was straight and you said
something to me that you thought I would
like you I did when I first met you it
was like cuz I had felt bad and it was
it was one of those things where in West
Hollywood I was like am I am i saying -
it might say I'm [ __ ] too much in my a
my ear you know cuz the one thing I
didn't want to do is I didn't want to
hurt you know my community cuz like it
or not those are my [ __ ] that's nothing
my brothers and sisters right there so I
was like alright maybe I need to back
off that what what what the [ __ ] am I
doing here you know it's not like they
they ostracized me they were just saying
why do you have to say [ __ ] so much
and for me it was like that's that's
what I grew up around like that's what I
heard and it didn't mean what it meant
to you when you heard it because it was
it was such a thing where I was like
listen that that is what like if we
weren't working fast enough I remember
my uncle buried come on you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and [ __ ] you I could not work and
it was like okay and I get what they
mean by you know how it can be
derogatory and I get that but like I
said I want I want to I want to gauge
oak that everybody can [ __ ] laugh at
that's that's what I really want like
that joke that you were referencing that
to me is is is something where I'm like
okay I think everybody can understand
this [ __ ] situation real yeah always
on stage and you had your Spencer
absolutely you're writing your life I
had to I had to text somebody to let him
know where I was the night I did that I
think that Saudi Arabian guy cuz I was
worried I was like hey if this is a
[ __ ] trick you need to know where the
[ __ ] my last thing was and like I I
can't I can't go missing I'll text you
and you know the guy that I'll text I'll
tell you it was after the show you know
it's crazy because I admire you I admire
you because at 55 I have no [ __ ] life
I have zero friends like that I do [ __ ]
with during the week and one man I
called him up like a were you and Eric
anything goes Eric got out of the car he
went on some gay happened he just
started walking and I'm like [ __ ] I wish
I could do that
just get on the [ __ ] app and meet
somebody on Magnolia Boulevard doing the
morning thing you know and it's just the
balls you have the safety you know when
I got into comedy I got into comedy
because of Lenny Bruce
nothing the father's [ __ ] thing from
Lenny Bruce like I'm scared to go home
past midnight Eric's like who's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] in this room who is it Joe
Diaz you know I said I told Lewis really
guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna call
them for spots at midnight at this door
I'm gonna drive on the 12th floor knee
up over that hill [ __ ] can happen though
I ain't gonna go I see who's become the
[ __ ] I have and this is what I gotta get
out of it I gotta get out of this this
did I told him I call this should change
this should changes when he gets dirty
I'm getting out of this road you know
I'm back at the store I'm going back
back to the store that going back to
this room yeah I'm going back to the
store maybe that's because that's not
the last I'm just getting warmed up
imitating going back to the straw
because that's where I belong
just a little [ __ ] foot and I was doing
a going to flat birds in the fourth wall
has to come to an end I gotta go down
there and that's why I was I was just
tipping around like I always do I have
the same problem as you people do at
home I procrastinate to write and I but
I do enough to get by and to fool
everybody
and I found I don't but I don't fool me
yeah fool me and it eats me up inside so
I said now I'm bored first off no that's
it I'm going to the store because I know
I would hate to go to the store because
I would hate the bomb I'm going down
here from now on to bomb like the other
night you know what I do
retail how scared I am of life well I
Drive to do Konami do you know I don't
put the radio on the car on the way
there
really you won't talk about people being
[ __ ] you won't talk about gay men even
gay guys listen to the radio before a
gig because they're [ __ ] excited not
me I'm taking it's in my head and I had
to get out of my head well I went to
Vegas and I've realized that both nights
I had done 50 minutes effort ly I was so
happy
no material let's go
like the old days if we get to it we get
to it and if we don't we don't I'm gonna
talk about what's on my mind in my heart
from now on whether you're liking him
that far care we do a half hour of it if
we go back to material we tiptoe around
the material but I'm a lot better when
I'm not scared I'm working the last two
years scared maybe that was your cell
phone in a way that was blocking you oh
yeah oh no no like I totally I got it I
got out of prison in 89 I didn't get on
stage till 91 took me two years because
I know is my life but I wish I would
cancel on Tuesday at 4:00 we know
something's gonna change our wife we
become such [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
ridiculous when something's going to
change my life
the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ] in the world
we all do and then we have the balls to
complain about this and talk about this
and talk about that so if you're scared
to do something that's gonna change your
life
go for it whether it's addiction whether
it's whatever the [ __ ] it is because I'd
do the same thing but that was the
reason why I wanted to have you on man
you're a [ __ ] powerhouse I think
you're gonna be a household name in a
few years and I'm happy you're friends
with me I am happy that you take care of
them yeah love you buddy took them on
the way you know you're gonna have a big
big adventure Pryor's they can I still
love their video saying that's still my
eyes I'm not as type every time
[ __ ] you're everybody's type your
short cute naive and you know nothing
about that I can have a but deaf-mute
talk gave the suck in his big ears oh
he's got the [ __ ] biggest heart yeah
that's the heart [ __ ] you no time to
[ __ ] in the heart they're just tight oh
my god don't forget you bad
[ __ ] this weekend we're in you
tied so that would Kate Quigley but
August 9th through the 11th I will be at
the beautiful improv in Kansas City with
my man Dean there I got some bad news to
report to you for tonight but it's good
news also number one I want to talk to
you people some buy something from the
heart here all right we all got problems
some people erections some people hear
something but listen just every problem
there's a solution and I got the
solution for you people tonight 66% of
men lose their hair by the age of 35
thing is when you start to notice hair
loss it's too late it's easier to keep
the hair you have until a place to hear
that you've lost let me ask you
something have you seen more forehead
than ever before as someone mentioned to
you that you have a bald spot that
wasn't there before have you noticed the
power hair and your brush or your comb
then you've never done this before have
you fixed your hair lately and just said
where the hell is my hair gun listen
thanks to science baldness could be an
option now the solution
for hems dot-com fo r hims comm capital
F and capital H a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care and sexual wellness for
men hims connects you with real doctors
and medical grade solutions to treat
hair loss without having to break the
bank well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair fda-approved prescription
solutions backed by science there's no
waiting rooms there's no awkward doctor
visits and you save hours by going to
four hems com what you're gonna do is
you're gonna hanser a few quick
questions upload some photos and the
doctor will prescribe you some
prescription meds that you need products
are shipped directly to your door
there's no middleman here for him has
even shared real before-and-after
Instagram photos posted by actual
clients and that are awesome or anything
you see they said let me see what you
can find
yeah so before and after pictures that
look just beautiful people are gonna
listen do me a favor why are we beating
around the bush alright I have a lot of
friends that suffer from male pattern
baldness and they eat some up alive it's
over with I want the church family gonna
trial month two hymns for five hours
today right now while supplies last go
to the website for hens calm and for
hims
dot-com slash Joey this would cost you
hundreds if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy I'm gonna save you a bunch of
money because that's what uncle Joey
does five hours today go there for hims
calms last Joey again go to for hims
calm slash Joey you got a problem we got
the solution for hims calm slash Joey
I'm gonna read you something I'm gonna
talk to you buy something that's gonna
hurt me more than it's gonna hurt you
anyway
you definitely heard me talk about me on
these before you know the fun their
company on these that feel as good as
they look
to those of you haven't tried them yet
listen up you're gonna you can get
incredible underwear sent right to your
door with me undies meaning no more
hang around for the perfect pair at the
crowded store and eventually selling for
good enough me and these are made with a
sustainable source material with
beechwood trees then naturally soft
fiber makes the fabric that won't sag
down or ride up like those [ __ ] white
underwear you wear with skid marks and
all that [ __ ] you get that neutral cup
that sits there trust me once you put a
pair of me on these on you'll get it
listen to me I've been wearing me on
these for seven years now they're the
best underwear in the market they keep
you clean they keep you moist your boss
smell good everything's no rashes no
heat rash in this hundred degree weather
me undies so sure that you'll love the
first pair that if you're not happy
don't do whatever the hell they can to
make it right and they'll get you the
right there and if they can't you keep
them and they'll refund you the money
who else does that it's risk free to try
the best underwear ever now if you're
already part of the me on these family
tell your friends about it through a
referral program then I'll get a
discount and you get store credit so
it's a win-win for everybody you're
still not sure let me tell you what I'm
going to do my first time and purchases
the church you'll get 15% off the first
pair me on these and free shipping why
because that's how uncle Joey does it
that's 15% off plus free shipping plus a
guarantee that me undies will be and you
will be happy together get your butt
over to me on these comm and treat
yourself alright you have 15% off your
first pair free shipping go to me
release calm slash Joey again that's me
on these comm slash Joey I want to thank
my new favorite comic mr. Eric wrote my
main [ __ ] Mane's you the Christ
killer but most importantly I want to
thank the best audience in the world you
guys for listening and for taking the
[ __ ] journey with me for the last
couple years I love you guys long my
heart like I told you I'll be in Utah
will be back Monday morning ready a
[ __ ] perky late ready to rock your
world all right I love you guys I love
you every grouchy love again I love you
Lisa I yet you guys have a great weekend
stay safe and stay black
Kansas City here we come take that
[ __ ] mule Lee